and ace adventurer who redefines the
rules of survival
Unite's with the leader of the world's
largest democracy
watch this dynamic duo where I'll kill
you from a father on an epic adventure
of a lifetime keeping the render Modi
alive a big job for Bear Grylls here's
what he had to say about his experience
in the wild with India's Prime Minister
you know our team that were filming I
was saying you know everyone was really
on edge but the Prime Minister was just
very calm and I think I saw that
throughout our journey whatever we were
doing he was actually very for Harry
sort of at one and that was a kind of
that was cool to see cuz you never know
really what some was like until you're
in a crisis but it was good to be
reminded that as a world leader
Prime Minister Modi is calm in a crisis
that's a good quality then either Modi
isn't the only world leader Bear Grylls
has hosted them an episode of his
program with he was out in the wilds of
Alaska in 2015 with then US President
Barack Obama but as expected this
apparent with Modi has set social media
ablaze this from the Prime Minister
himself what better than the last green
jungles of India in the midst of Mother
Nature to throw light on environmental
conservation and climate change and
Modi's appearance on the episode has
prompted a number of memes such as this
one from this user referencing the
annual monsoon flooding in Mumbai the
epic adventure of a lifetime
others thought Modi was spending way too
much time talking about his own life
coat I was poor I salty this is the
first vacation I've had in 18 years all
while Bear Grylls waits patiently to eat
a grasshopper
and the fact that Modi spoke almost
exclusively in Hindi also came in for
comment Modi is a magician he speaks
Hindi and Bear Grylls understands
everything for more let's go across to
DW correspondent nimisha Jay as well
standing by in Delhi new shop good to
see you now a lot of reactions they're
appearing on social
Media for those who haven't watched the
episode what were the main highlights
well Krrish the main highlights of the
episode basically involved perilous
taking Prime Minister Narendra Modi
through a Wildlife Sanctuary but also
stopping several times along the way to
speak with the Prime Minister about his
own views on environmental conservation
his childhood his past his personal
inclinations as a politician and of
course Prime Minister Narendra Modi
spoke about the importance of
environmental conservation to him and to
all Indians but also referred often to
his childhood to his humble origins and
to the way he works and to his endless
dedication to his work and this of
course in a fashion is playing to his
strengths because many of Prime Minister
Narendra Modi's supporters actually
value his political career and his
political presence because of these
humble origins
so of course Prime Minister playing to
his strengths and being received just as
much and his supporters speaking of them
they are also trying to seize on the
message of environmental conservation
something that Narendra Modi himself
tweeted out what about it what is the
record of the BJP government led by
Narendra Modi on environmental
conservation the aspirations the
emphasis was on environmental
conservation even when this program was
first teased Prime Minister Narendra
Modi said that this will highlight
India's diversity and the importance of
conservation in India but on the other
hand critics have pointed out that this
stand is ironic because this government
has been criticized for diluting
environmental protections it has been
criticized for diluting forest
protection that act the Falls Protection
Act the environmental impact Act and
also making green laws easier on
businesses all in the stance of
promoting development they've actually
reduced the amount of time it needs to
get environmental clearances so this is
something that this government has
actually received heavy criticism about
a message as well in Delhi thank you
very much for that